where do things stand right now let's
bring in two of the best in the business
at this topic that can read between the
or up and down
the lines uh here now is gordon chang
senior fellow the gatestone institute
and author of the great u.s china tech
war and stephen mosher is here president
of the population research institute and
author of bully of asia uh gordon let's
start with you
uh statements aside there was a lot at
stake today
what was the goal for president biden
and do you think he got there
president biden wanted clarified china's
role because there have been a lot of
statements from chinese officials and
from propaganda outlets and i actually
don't think that he did that because
what he got in return really were
statements of generality from xi jinping
we picked that from the xinhua release
but also some ambiguous statements like
china didn't want to see the result in
the ukraine war which probably meant
something along the lines of we're very
sad to see see the vladimir putin being
beaten up by the ukrainians so i i don't
think that uh the chinese were terribly
impressed with the warnings and indeed
we're going to have to impose sanctions
on china if we want to move the chinese
in the right direction and biden has not
been willing to do that yet
steve that's one thing that china does
not want they don't want the secondary
sanctions they're not really loving the
fact that they'll be best friends with
the pariah of the world at this moment
it's not in their best interest to make
it so apparent it seems to be best
buddies with russia and do whatever they
ask correct
well correct but remember that china
encouraged putin's invasion of ukraine
hoping to embroil the us in the conflict
i think he's been taken aback by the
robustness of the response by the
ukrainian people and also by the
response of the world brian because look
australia and japan in his neighborhood
neighborhood she's neighborhood are
joining in to sanction china so the
russian bet isn't looking so smart now
and pay attention to the fact that the
uh the ambassador to ukraine from china
ambassador fans said in this situation
he told the ukrainian people we will act
responsibly seeing how great the unity
of the ukrainian people is and that
means it's trained so i think that he's
saying that china is seeing that it's
not a walk in the park for putin if
putin had seized kiev in a couple of
weeks installed a puppet regime and the
world had yawn saying well that was
historically russian territory anyway
let's just look away it would be one
thing but that's not how it's working
out so might she betray putin might he
retreat from the agreement they just
signed of course but not because biden
asked him to today or any other day they
would retreat because biden is putin is
looking more like a loser every day just
as russia of course is no longer a
superpower it's looking less and less
like a superpower every day
and gordon you're always good at
you you see the numbers but then you see
the story behind the numbers i see a gdp
that's been very growing very slow for
them it's about five i see the omnicron
virus hitting them hard and hurting
their economy again and their people
obviously i also see something else i
see all the nationalizing of industries
they're putting down of entrepreneurship
and the degree of free enterprising
really affecting their growth in their
economy do you think they really need
sanctions at this time especially with
president xi up for his fi another five
year term
yeah sanctions at this time would make
china extremely vulnerable you know they
claimed 8.1 percent gross domestic
product growth last year but even by
their own numbers they show that their
economy is slowing fast because they
only claim 4.0 growth in the fourth
quarter and and and you know brian those
numbers are exaggerated they've got a
debt crisis they can't get passed
omicron as you pointed out is shutting
down large portions of the chinese
economy including shenzhen and the south
which is critical for the tech sector
and their markets have really gone into
retreat and they would have stayed at
the bottom had it not been for a
government announcement a couple days
ago so now china is where we want it and
the question is whether biden has the
will to push china by imposing those
sanctions i don't think that he has
because he doesn't really want to do
that
steve final thought the president is
using the same approach with bill back
better as he's doing with china but the
stakes are much higher he couldn't he
could not convince joe manchin to do
what he asked and they're in the same
party can he convince president xi to
not give arms to not give weapons to not
give not by the oil of russia
no i mean china look is bound on its own
trajectory through time they will
operate always and ever more in the
interest of the chinese communist party
their own interests and lastly perhaps
in the interest of the chinese people
that is of course last i wish that we
had a government that was capable of
acting in the interest of the american
people in this situation and in all
situations and sadly we don't i mean
look we have a president in the white
house whose family has taken money from
ukraine russia and china all of the
major players uh i think he's fatally
compromised
well
uh my hope is that china understands uh
that there are fading power in russia
and it's to their advantage to deal with
a new newly reunited europe and that's
probably the best we can hope for thanks
guys have a great weekend
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now